the paramount network series yellowstone
has over the course of its four seasons
become one of its most popular hits so
fans of the series were naturally
excited to learn that a prequel had been
green lit by the network with
yellowstone co-creator taylor sheridan
serving as the soul creator this time
around marking his second collaboration
with the streaming service paramount
plus after the crime drama mayor of
kingstown
the show titled 1883 follows the
ancestors of the dutton family who are
the focus of yellowstone and stars sam
elliott billy bob thornton lamonica
garrett tim mcgraw and faith hill their
characters journey from texas to montana
coming across all kinds of treacherous
threats to lay claim to what would
eventually become the dutton ranch fans
of yellowstone know all too well the
kinds of headaches that accompany owning
a piece of property that large in the
modern era and if the modern day duttons
thought they had it bad james and
margaret dutton are about to show the
world how much worse it can get there
have been numerous reasons for fans to
get excited from the time period to the
pedigree of creator taylor sheridan
however above all else the show has one
of the most stellar casts in any modern
day drama especially when it comes to
the casting of real life couple mcgraw
and hill in a recent interview mcgraw
revealed that the cast of the show could
have looked quite different if a certain
stipulation hadn't been met this is the
one condition under which mcgraw agreed
to star in 1883. tim mcgraw is country
music royalty with faith hill as his
queen the two have been married since
1996 and have three children together so
they have one of the longest running
marriages in the entertainment industry
by far
while the two have shared the stage
plenty of times in the past they've
surprisingly never acted together
despite both of them having rather
extensive filmographies in an interview
with the youtube channel dc film girl
tim mcgraw was asked about the fact that
both he and his wife faith hill are in
the series with the interviewer
wondering if that was part of the
stipulation for him doing the show in
the first place mcgraw replied that the
end result was the same but the route
was different mcgraw clarified we had
done a flashback scene or two for
yellowstone's last season and that was
how this whole idea came about of doing
the prequel series and so once we had
done the flashback sequence we were sort
of married to each other so to speak as
it were anyway the country music
superstar added that having his wife on
the show was part of the deal saying
when it came time to do this show we
were definitely going to do it together
period we loved the writing so much and
there was no way we were going to do it
separately but i think they were kind of
stuck with us anyway tim mcgraw and
faith hill are both country mega stars
so it's a big deal for them to star in
1883 together undoubtedly other projects
must have come along over the years with
various movies and tv shows wanting the
power couple to hop aboard what about
1883 was different from all of those
in a separate interview with dc film
girl the host had a chance to speak with
faith hill and she asked what made her
want to play margaret dutton hill said
that it was the writing
taylor sheridan does the bulk of the
writing on both yellowstone and 1883 and
he has numerous other westerns and
neo-westerns to his name he's one of the
hottest writers in hollywood right now
so it makes sense mcgraw and hill would
want to hitch their wagon metaphorically
speaking to the artist hill goes on to
elaborate it's one of the best things
i've ever read truthfully and yeah that
was really it it was the writing the
story of this family it'll be
interesting to see how the tale of james
and margaret influences the modern day
story of yellowstone but for now you can
see how mcgraw and hill's real-life
relationship translates on screen when
the first season of 1883 continues on
sundays on paramount plus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the world of yellowstone are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]